[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new marvel x-men video we
have some good news for a change there
are things to look forward to so there's
a new Disney Plus teaser for new marvel
x-men content and actually everyone was
going crazy this morning trying to
figure out what it means there's a lot
of x-men stuff going on behind the
scenes at Marvel Studios since they got
the rights back to all their characters
from the Fox Steel so we'll break it all
down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing that Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave all your theories about what
this means on the video so I'll just go
down the list of the projects that
they've already talked about that we
know that they're working on and what
this is most likely going to be starting
with number 5 if you didn't see the last
day or so people started to notice that
there's a new section and Disney Plus
that started showing a bunch of new
x-men artwork like they're creating a
new destination for Marvel x-men content
in Disney Plus that's brand new x-men
content there's brand new artwork of
them in their costumes from x-men the
animated series but because all the
episodes from the classic x-men the
animated series have already been on
Disney Plus since it launched last year
all this new teaser and artwork didn't
show up connected to that stuff so
that's why everyone thinks that this is
Marvel creating a section where they're
going to be putting some new x-men
project on Disney Plus the Disney CEO
said that one of their biggest
priorities now is growing their Disney
Plus subscriber base the only way to do
that the big hook to get people to pay
for it is brand new content for the past
year Kevin Feige has been talking about
them working on new Marvel x-men
projects that's multiple different
projects when people think about that
they're mostly thinking about the new
full-blown x-men Marvel MCU movie with
rebooted versions of the characters that
is happening in the background but all
the new x-men projects that they're
working on include one-off mutants and
x-men characters being introduced in
other movies like black panther 2 or
even Captain Marvel - if rumors are to
be believed and it also includes
straight-up Disney Plus series with
x-men and mutant characters normally
when we talk about the x-men we're
talking about the core x-men team but
technically the term applies to all the
Fox Marvel characters usually only
Deadpool and the Fantastic Four are
spoken of separately even though
technically Fox had the rights
to Deadpool because he was included in
all the Marvel rights when they
initially licensed the characters after
Marvel went bankrupt in the 90s a lot of
people wondering if they're creating
more sections for x-men content in
Disney Plus as a precursor to releasing
new mutants video on demand instead of
trying to push it to way later this year
in theaters the reason why I don't think
this is connected to New Mutants though
it's just because it would probably have
some new mutants specific artwork in all
these new teasers number four there have
been a lot of x-men Easter eggs in the
MCU in the live-action films I've
already done a couple videos recently
about that especially for the Wolverine
character so I'll link those at the end
of this so it could be the beginnings of
Marvel just creating a dedicated section
for their new live-action x-men Marvel
movie content but I think this is less
likely just because Marvel hasn't
announced a release date for that new
Marvel MCU x-men movie we just know that
it's happening at some point during
Marvel phase 5 they haven't really given
us any hints as to who they're looking
at in terms of actors and the sting of
x-men Dark Phoenix is still so fresh
they're using the next couple of years
to develop new x-men movie projects just
kind of hoping that after a bunch of
time goes by fewer people will associate
the bad x-men movies with the new x-men
movies when Marvel does start talking
about their new version of the x-men and
they just killed off Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in the Logan movie a few years
ago Kevin Feige understands they need to
pay their respects and not rush to
recast the character right away fans
would be pissed if they rolled out a
brand new Wolverine next year number
three there was a brand new Deadpool
animated series that almost wound up
airing on FX networks made by Donald
Glover an animation studio even released
a teaser trailer for it in everything
this is a clip from that giving you an
idea of what it would have felt like
[Applause]
this but don't swallow
the promises gets worse for you big boy
I'm touching no joke that was gonna be a
rated R Deadpool animated series that
would have been bad ass
but before FX could order more episodes
Marvel opted to cancel the project
mostly because they didn't like the way
Donald Glover was writing Deadpool's
jokes and using him for social
commentary you may remember this from a
couple years ago Donald Glover posted
all these script pages that he wrote
where he shaded Marvel TV people
hardcore but it was the Marvel TV people
it wasn't Kevin Feige in the Marvel
Studios people recently they just had
that big culling there was a huge
bloodbath now all of Marvel TV is part
of Marvel Studios and Kevin Feige
controls everything all the TV shows all
the movies and all the comics as well so
while I do think that they're still
trying to create an animated Deadpool
series because that'd be an easy
slam-dunk I don't think that that would
be part of this new Disney Plus x-men
related content just because it would be
more mature and Disney Plus is supposed
to be more pg-13 and family-friendly
stuff hopefully someday we'll see a
hardcore Deadpool animated series on
Hulu or something like that because
Disney owns Hulu now so that's where all
their Deadpool content is probably gonna
live number two a little more likely
this Disney Plus x-men teaser could just
be the beginnings of an x-men
live-action Disney Plus series with
lesser mutant characters like scarlet
witch's children Wiccan in speed which
we see during the wand division trailer
like a lot of people when I first saw
that footage I just assumed it was the
beginnings of Marvel doing mutants in
the MCU and because Disney Plus series
are meant to be for that pg-13 younger
audience Marvel would just start doing
the DC TV show thing on Disney Plus
where you have a bunch of interconnected
TV series but a lot of them are younger
characters really good example of that
is the Miss Marvel series that are doing
on Disney Plus she's around the same age
as Tom Hollands spider-man not that
young but also not that old either you
also have the Caped character debuting
during the Hawkeye series so there's
just a lot of really young characters
showing up on Disney Plus so it just
seems like the place if you're gonna do
a big young character team-up and Young
Avengers would be an easy slam-dunk for
that but you need some of those Fox
Marvel characters but number one just
based on all the evidence and the
interviews they've done so far I think
it's most likely this new x-men teaser
is Marvel doing a new version or new
episodes of x-men the animated series
some new project related to x-men the
animated series I know how you feel
about it Wolverine Warner Brothers in DC
brought back Young Justice the exact
same way for their streaming service DC
Universe Kevin Feige is reportedly a big
fan of the classic x-men the animated
series they have a lot of that classic
content on the service already in The
Hollywood Reporter even talked to the
creators of the original x-men the
animated series and they said that they
had pitched a revival of the series to
Marvel a little while ago so this might
be Marvel finally making good on that
pitch but like I said the real hook
getting people to subscribe to Disney
Plus and pay for it is releasing brand
new content the fun backstory on why
they cancelled x-men the animated series
because I loved watching that series
when I was a little kid reportedly Fox
canceled the series mostly because they
didn't like that Marvel still controlled
their most popular animated series and
they were getting ready to make a
live-action x-men film and this was
around the time of the Marvel bankruptcy
when they were licensing their
characters out so was right around the
time that Fox gain control of the
live-action x-men properties and they
wanted full control of the x-men
characters but you still have Marvel
Studios that has the rights to the
animated series and if you're a big fan
of that classic spider-man the animated
series it's also the same reason why
they canceled that because that was
airing around the same time as the
classic x-men the animated series if any
part of me
anything like the real Mary Jane Watson
she loves Peter Parker with anything in
the world
[Music]
so everyone let me know in the comments
what kind of new x-men related project
do you think that Marvel is teasing for
Disney Plus we're gonna start seeing
more x-men Easter eggs and mutants
through the Disney Plus series like
Falcon and Winter Soldier in one
division this year so I'll be doing more
Easter egg videos for that leave all
your video requests in the comments
below
congratulations our W stew for your the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
I just did a big video for spider-man 3
and all the new canceled and delayed
Marvel movies they just announced you
can click here for that and click here
for all my brand new Marvel Wolverine
Weapon X Easter eggs in the MCU movies
thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe
see you guys tonight
[Music]